[Music]
i like that music welcome back to cbs
this morning millions of americans
cannot wait to get a covet-19 vaccine
but many women undergoing fertility
treatment say they are afraid to get the
needle
doctors say there is no evidence
whatsoever that the vaccines can lead to
infertility
but that has not stopped baseless rumors
from spreading online
nikki bates spoke with two women about
concerns that the vaccine could affect
their ability to get pregnant nikki good
morning to you
gail good morning a fertility treatment
is already an incredibly
personal and emotional journey add to it
a pandemic and of course it becomes even
more difficult
i spoke with stacy clark a 36 year old
nurse who in just a few days will find
out if her embryo transfer was
successful
about why she fears a vaccine could
jeopardize her chance
to have a child there's a lot of emotion
because i've gone through this twice
before it wasn't successful
thirty-six-year-old stacy clark has seen
what kofi can do
as a nurse during this pandemic yet she
says she still
fears the vaccine as much as the virus
what if there is something in there that
wasn't tested
will it cause you know females
to be sterile and clark is hardly alone
how often are you being asked by
patients if the vaccine
causes infertility so every day jay
huber is clark's fertility doctor
in new orleans he says there's no
evidence that covert vaccine causes
infertility
what is the biggest misconception this
concept that
the vaccination will actually train the
human immune system to create an
antibody that can cross react
with that vital placental protein which
would ultimately
cause infertility is there any truth to
it at all
we don't have any data to suggest that
there is any truth to it
he says some of the confusion and
concern comes from a small segment of
dna
that the placental protein and covid
antibody share we will give you some
antibiotics
still he empathizes with patients like
41 year old nicole linsley
it just leaves me feeling uneasy who are
unwilling to take a chance
how much of this decision is that you
don't trust the vaccine at all or that
you're worried about introducing
something that might interfere with your
fertility
journey it's more about introducing
something into my
journey of fertility that i'm not sure
what it will do clark says many female
colleagues of child bearing age
share her fears what are your
discussions about the vaccine with dr
hoover been like he of course very much
feels
that there's enough evidence for me to
get the vaccine he
has absolutely respected my decision so
we've come to an agreement
for the time being you agree to disagree
yes
not even this cautionary tale from 35
year old
anna almadralla she came down with covid
after her last
fertility treatment i will always love
you
days later she was in the hospital
writing this goodbye letter to her
three-year-old daughter
what do you say to women who are
hesitant or do not want the vaccine at
all who are also going for fertility
treatments
with the virus so widespread you're
either choosing between getting the
vaccine or getting coveted
fortunately amendrala recovered and is
grateful there is a vaccine
she will gladly take it when it's her
turn i think what this experience has
really shown us is that
we already have so much to be grateful
for i was a couple days away from
losing everything
the fda has cleared both the moderna and
pfizer vaccine for
use in women of child bearing age
although no pregnant women were included
in the vaccine trials
a few dozen who participated did become
pregnant
tony nikki thank you very much i mean
the stakes are so high when you're when
you're trying to have a child that
you can understand you want to take
every precaution yeah i get it
i really felt for stacey clark and i
could see why you're so concerned and
worried because there's still so much
that's not known
yeah and it's still so much about and
like nikki said at the top it's a
personal decision at the end of the day